assessing the damage of India's worst
rail accident in decades prime minister
Narendra Modi visits the site of the
tragedy in balasore in odisha state the
destruction is overwhelming the loss
immeasurable
hundreds of people died in the crash
a rescue and Recovery operation marked
with bodies scattered across the tracks
passengers fear trapped in overturned
carriages the scene survivors say looked
like a war zone
The Carriage started shaking we got
scared when we realized what was going
on we tried to get out we broke the
windows and managed to get out the
accident happened when a passenger Train
derailed and collided with a freight
train on a nearby track minutes later a
third train plowed into the wreckage
[Music]
nearby hospitals are overwhelmed
families of the victims desperately wait
for updates hoping their loved ones
survived faced with limited medical
resources people have lined up in
clinics ready to donate blood
there is no greatest satisfaction than
to save someone's life by donating blood
and that is why we volunteered
more than 12 million people commute in
the country's Railways every day
accidents are common but not of this
scale
already a high-level committee has been
formed to look into this incident the
rail safety commissioner will also do an
inquiry and they will go and find the
root cause of this accident why did this
happen all the technical details would
be found out by them
and has invested heavily in India's
Railway network but outdated equipment
continues to be a problem and a
liability